when markets get choppy investors can
pull out to save their money or they can
cast their lines for discounted stock
aiming for a bigger profit later on this
second option is called buying the dip
and it's been a popular strategy in the
markets for years now it was even touted
during the crash of 2008. this is not a
time to be selling your stocks it's
times like these where people really
make money because stocks become a
better value but so far in 2022 buying
the dip hasn't paid off as well as in
the past markets are volatile and in
this environment buying the dip can be
risky what we're seeing is that after
people step in to buy the stock market
dip the s p 500 has kept falling the day
after so that means that you're sitting
on a loss pretty quickly
but even these circumstances haven't
stopped investors who want to bring in a
big catch here's why it's such an
attractive strategy but nearly
impossible to time
let's zoom out buying the dip is when
investors purchase assets after they
have dropped in price on the assumption
that their value will bounce back what
we've seen over the past few decades
is that sharp downturns in the stock
market have often been followed by these
huge rebounds so people that have sat on
the sidelines during say the financial
crisis or the march 2020 covet crash
have watched stocks kind of go up after
those instances
investors willing to dive in tend to
have one of three main motivations first
some investors want to buy into growing
companies they care less about the price
of the stock and more about the
opportunity to reel in a company they
think will experience significant growth
in the future other investors look for
stocks with upward momentum meaning
rising prices they're most interested in
timing the bottom of the dip so they can
maximize profits and then there's
investors who want cheap stocks they
don't care as much about how fast and
how far their stocks will grow but
they're excited that stocks that were
previously expensive are now cheap
enough for them to grab
mainly they think the stocks they're
buying will keep going up whatever their
motivation if a lot of investors attempt
this strategy the results can have
another effect one that has played out
in the past few years as more individual
investors have entered the market
individual investors have become such a
prominent force in markets in recent
years they've stampeded into the markets
they've bought a record amount of stocks
so some analysts and strategists do say
that they can kind of provide a backstop
to the market and help support the
market
during volatility sometimes when enough
investors try to catch cheap stocks they
can actually reverse the downward
trajectory take for example the 2008
crash after the housing bubble burst it
sent markets into a tailspin but by 2009
many investors began re-entering the
market pushing up the prices of cheap
stocks investors halted a three-day
losing streak sending stocks broadly
higher on a weaker dollar and better
than expected home sales numbers it was
known as the 2009 dash for trash we saw
that that prolonged downturn that steep
sell-off was was followed by an
incredible recovery an 11-year bull
market for stocks the msci all-country
world index ended up returning its best
annual performance on record in 2009
just after its worst performance in
2008.
people who said the stock market is too
scary for me right now they missed out
on those mammoth mammoth gains and and
may have regretted it strategists say
that since then investors have been
conditioned to buy the dip and it's made
individual investors money at least
until 2022. since the federal reserve
has made the biggest interest rate
increase since 2000 some think a
recession is ahead this is a huge shift
for financial markets and that's one of
the key reasons we've seen this
volatility it's an example of why it can
be so hard for investors to time the dip
because stocks can keep on falling vanda
research estimates the average
individual investor portfolio peaked
late in 2021 and then tumbled losing an
average of about 28 by may 9th
with all the dangers associated with
buying the dip it's no wonder that
analysts consider it risky if you choose
to buy the dip
you can't expect you know the market to
bounce immediately it could take days
weeks months or even years for it to
rebound and for you to pocket a profit
on that trade
[Music]